Hopefully, you've got used to
straight forward titles in computer
science by now.
If so, you might be able to guess
that the Shortest Path Problem
is all about finding
the shortest path in a graph.
Early on,
we talked about weighted edges,
where the edges in a graph have some
numeric value associated with them.
The shortest path is the one where
the sum of the edges is as small
as possible.
If we had an unweighted graph,
the shortest path would just be the one
with the fewest number of edges.
The nature of the solution to this
problem changes a lot depending on
the type of graph.
For example, the solution to
the Shortest Path Problem for
an unweighted graph is actually just
a breath first search, with the BFS,
you start at one node and visit
the closest nodes first, slowly moving
out to more distant nodes until you
find the one that you were looking for.
Again, when there's no weights,
you just want to find the path
with the least number of edges.